القوات الصيدليه تقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين في
عمليه اقتحام لبله جبع في محافظه جنين
غاراتيه عنيفه على
نوويه دون كهرباء ومقتل اربعه
الشارع والاحتجاجات العنيفه برلمان جورجيا
يسحب قانون الوكلاء الاجانب
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نبدا نشاه من تطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه التي تشهد توترا امليا متزايدا
كل يوم المواجهات يتركز في الفتره الاخيره
في منطقه جنين شمال الضفه الغربيه حيث
تنفذ القوات الاسرائيليه اقتحامات متكرره
بحثا عن مطلوبين في هذا السياق مشاهدينا
افاد مراد العربيه بمقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين
على الاقل بعد استهداف سيارتهم في بلده
جابع جنوب ومحافظه جنين في الضفه الغربيه
هذا وقت حمت القوات الاسرائيليه البلديه
وحاصرت مجموعه من الفلسطينيين ما ادى الى
اندلاع اشتباكاتنا عنيفه في المكان انتهت
بمقتل ثلاثه من المحاصرين وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه اعلنت وفاه طفل متاثر بجروحه
التي اصيب بها قبل يومين في الهجوم
الاسرائيلي على جنين ما يرفع حصيره
الضحايا الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه العام الى
78 شخصا منهم واحد وثلاثون شخصا من جنين
وحدها
قوات خاصه
خزك وهاي السياره هونداي اكسنت اي هونداي
نزلوا من الجيب ومن الباص
عمليه الاسرائيليه حدثت الساعه السادسه
فجرا وفق الروايه الاسرائيليه فان قوه
خاصه تتبع للجهاز الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي
كانت تتابع مجموعه من المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين والناشطين الذين يتبعون
لكتيبه جنين القوى الاسرائيليه حاولت
ايقاف مركبتهم عندما كانوا يحاولون
الانتقال من بلده جبع الى مدينه جنينه
التي لا تبعد سوى بضعه كيلومترات
المقاتلون الفلسطينيون رفضوا التوقف
وحاولوا المقاومه باطلاق النار على القوى
الاسرائيليه التي ردت وقامت بقتل الثلاثه
شبان فلسطينيين داخل السياره اثنان منهم
يتبعون لسرايا القدس واحد من حركه فتح
وكلهم ناشطين في كتيبه جنين هذا وفق
الروايه الاسرائيليه الروايه الفلسطينيه
تقول ان كمينا محكما
وضعته القوات الاسرائيليه منذ فجر هذا
اليوم قوه اسرائيليه خاصه كانت تتخفى في
مركبه مدنيه نصبت كمينا وكانت تراقب هؤلاء
الشبان وحاله مرور سيارتهم فتحت عليهم
النار بشكل مباشر ولم تعطيهم اي فرصه
للتسليم نفسهم ولا للمقاومه بعد ذلك
اندلعت اشتباكات ايضا بين مجموعه من
الناشطين الفلسطينيين في بلده جبع بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي حاصر احد المباني
فيها هذه الاشتباكات استمرت نحو ساعه
بعدها انسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي من بلده جبع
ومن محافظه جنين بشكل عام وتم نقل جثامين
الشبان الى مستشفى
الجنين الحكومي اضافه يعني لعمليه تشييع
التي ستجري بعد قليل للشبان الثلاثه هناك
ايضا طفل رابع اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه عن وفاته متاثرا بجروحه في
الهجوم الذي تم على جنين قبل يومين والذي
ادى الى مقتل سته فلسطينيين يعني عبد
الحفيظ من ذلك ان استهداف هؤلاء شبان ياتي
في سياق عمليات استباقيه ام انهم من
المطلوبين للسلطات الاسرائيليه
نعم هي سلسله من العمليات المكثفه التي
تقوم بها القوات الاسرائيليه سواء في
عمليات اقتحام للمدن عمليات اقتحام كبرى
كما جرى في نابلس والجنين او في وضع
الحواجز او عمليات الاعتقال او عمليات
الاغتيال المباشره التي اصبحنا نشاهدها
بشكل مكثف تقوم بها القوات الاسرائيليه
وفق المصادر الاسرائيليه والجيش
الاسرائيلي فان هؤلاء الشبان كانوا يعدون
لعمليه او مسؤولين عن عمليات اطلاق نار
متكرره صوب اهداف اسرائيليه ولكن هذا ياتي
في سياق تصعيد مستمر وما يصل فيه
الفلسطينيون بشلال دماء متواصل منذ بدايه
هذا العام والذي نشهد فيه تكثيفا كبيرا
للعمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه على مختلف
انواعها سواء في الاقتحام في الاغتيال في
الحواجز وايضا نشهد نشرا كبيرا للقوات
الاسرائيليه وتكثيفا في تواجدها في مختلف
مدن الضفه الغربيه من شمالها الى جنوبها
طيب اشرت ايضا الى ان بلده جامع تستعد في
هذه اللحظات التشييع ابنائها الذين
قتلوا في هذه العمليه لكن هل من مؤشرات او
دعوات تصعيد شعبي محتمل سواء في هذه
المنطقه او بقيه المناطق الفلسطينيه
البارحه كان هناك اضراب شامل في مختلف مدن
الضفه الغربيه ربما هذا اليوم ايضا هناك
اضراب في مدينه جنين حدادا على ارواح
هولاء الشبان دعوات التصدي للقوات
الاسرائيليه دعوات تنفيذ عمليات متواصله
من مختلف الفصائل الفلسطينيه سواء في
الضفه الغربيه او حتى في قطاع غزه حتى
هناك خشيه من ان تتصاعد الامور على قطاع
غزه قبل قليل كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث
ان قواته استنفرت في محيط قطاع غزه خشيه
من ان تقوم حركات فلسطينيه في قطاع غزه من
اطلاق صواريخ ايضا في القدس البارحه كان
هناك ايعاز من قياده الشرطه الاسرائيليه
بتكثيف القوات خشيه من عمليات رد فلسطينيه
وهذا احمد ما بيتنا نراه يعني منذ بدايه
هذا العام كل عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه ياتي
بعدها رد فلسطيني ولكن قد يختلف في الحجم
وفي المكان سواء في الداخل او في الضفه
الغربيه نحو اهداف استيطانيه طيب هل الوضع
افضل حالا في حوار التي اقتحمتها القوات
الاسرائيليه يوم امس وقدره ايضا سته
فلسطينيين
عفوا لما اسمع حوار اسالك عن حوار عبد
الحفيظ التي اقتحمتها ايضا قوات القوات
الاسرائيليه يوم امس وقتلت سته فلسطينيين
على اثر هذا الاقتحام كيف يبدو المشهد
فيها
نعم يعني في حواره للمشهد يعني صعب للغايه
ما زال الكثير من الفلسطينيين يخشون فتح
متاجرهم فتح المحلات الجيش الاسرائيلي
ينتشر فيها بشكل كبير حواره تحديدا ترتبط
بما حدث يوم امس يوم امس كان الاول امس
كان الاقتحام لجنين ولكن كان الهدف هو من
نفذوا عمليه حواره وتحديدا اتحدث اتحدث عن
عبد الفتاح خروش الذي تتهمه القوات
الاسرائيليه بقتل مستوطنين في حواره
وبالتالي كان نقل لجثمان هذا الشخص من
جنين الى نابلس عبر حواره وبالتالي كانت
توتر مازال متواصلا وكان هناك احتفال
للمستوطنين لان القوات الاسرائيليه تمكنت
من قتل هذا الشخص المسؤول عن قتل مستوطنين
اثنين في حواره ولكن هذه البلده ومعظم
البلدات جنوب جنين ما زالت تعاني بشكل
متواصل نتيجه لهجمات المستوطنين المتواصله
سواء في الهجوم على المنازل على مركبات
الفلسطينيين او حتى الهجوم على المزارعين
الذين يحاولون حراسه ارضهم او تقليم
الاشجار وما الى ذلك سنبقى في متابعه
دائما معك عبد الحفيظ لاي تطورات في هذا
الملف شكرا لك من رام الله كنت معنا مؤسسه
العربيه عبد الحفيظ جعوان
مشاهدينا في الداخل الاسرائيلي افاد مراسل
العربيه بان وزير الدفاع الامريكي لن يدخل
اسرائيل وسيجي لقاءاته في المطار وذلك وسط
انتشار امني كثيف مسؤولون امريكيون
واسرائيليون اكدوا قبل ذلك بان وزاد دفاع
الامريكي اضطر الى تغيير جدول الزياره
المقرره اليوم الخميس لاسرائيل وتغيير
مكان انعقاد اجتماعي في مصنع بالقرب من
مطار اسرائيل الدولي بناء على طلب وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه حيث سيلتقي اوستن رئيس
الوزراء بن امينه نياهو ونظيره الاسرائيلي
واوضح المسؤولون ان التغيير طرا بسبب
الاحتجاجات المناهضه لحكومه نتنياهو التي
من المتوقع ان تشل حركه المرور في جميع
انحاء البلاد مع توقع اغلاق الطرق وتحذير
السلطات من اضطرابات محتمله في المطر
متابعه للحرب الاوكرانيه اعلن مسؤولون
اوكرانيون مقتل خمسه اشخاص واصابه عدد اخر
جراء الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه وذكر حاكم
اوديسا غربيه اوكرانيا ذكر ان اربعه اشخاص
قتلوا في الغارات بينما قتل شخص واحد
وذكر الجيش الاوكراني من جهته ذكر او تحدث
عن اسقاط خمسه عشر صاروخا فوق لايف وكانت
الضربه الصاروخيه الروسيه المكثفه امتدت
الى مناطق اخرى بينها العاصمه كييف حيث
انقطعت الكهرباء عن 40% من السكان بحسب
الاداره العسكريه
ونشاهد في خبر عاجل الجيش الاوكراني يتحدث
عن ان روسيا اطلقت واحد وثمانين صاروخا
وثماني طائرات مسيره في هجمات اليوم
وفيما يتصل المشاهدين عفوا نتصل بالهجوم
على خط انابيبورد السليم وصف للخارجيه
الامريكيه على لسان المتحدث باسمها
التقارير التي تتحدث عن تورط واشنطن في
تفجيرات
انابيبها واكد برايس ان واشنطن لا ترفض اي
روايات تشير الى العثور على متورطين في
هذا الحادث وعن تورز اوكرانيا في
التفجيرات قال ان امريكا لا تستبعد هذا
الامر
اكد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوري الاستمراريه التحقيق
في تفجير خط لوردستريم وذلك بعد ان نقلت
وسائل اعلام عن مسؤولين امريكيين مجهولين
ترجيحهم مسؤوليه جماعه مواليد اوكرانيا عن
الهجوم
لست خائفا من الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن تكهنات
اما التحقيقات فما زالت جاريه في السويد
والدنمارك والمانيا طالما التحقيقات
مستمره فلا نستطيع استخلاص نتائج نهائيه
يجب الانتظار لفهم ما يحدث
يجري صباح اليوم في العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
وزير خارجيه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان ال سعود لبحث جمله
من القضايا بينها العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين والازمه الاوكرانيه
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
يتحدى المحتجين ويقر رفع سن التقاعد الى
64 عاما
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد قالت مديره
المخابرات الوطنيه الامريكيه ان ايران
سرعت من جهودها واصبحت قريبه جدا من
الوصول الى القنبله النوويه
اكثر ما يقلقنا ان ايران سرعت برنامجها
النووي بسبب انها لم تعد مقيده بالاتفاق
النووي ونفذت ابحاثا وانشطه قربتها كثيرا
من انتاج الماده الانشطاريه الضروريه
لانتاج سلاح نووي اذا تم اتخاذ قرار بذلك
الدول الاوروبيه ثلاث فرنسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا حذرت ايران من ان عدم تقديمها
اجوبه مقنع الوكاله حول سبب العثور على
اثار يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه 84% بشكل سريع
سيعرضها للمحاسبه
في جورجيا مشاهدينا اعلان الحزب الحاكم ان
البرلمان سحب مشروع قانون الوكلاء الاجانب
المثير للجدل عقب احتجاجات عارمه في
البلاد هذا واستخدمت الشرطه الجورجيه
خراطيم المياه في محاوله لتفريق
المتظاهرين الذين احتشدوه بالقرب يبنى
البرلمان في العاصمه ابليسي اعتراضا على
مصادقه اوليه من النواب الجورجيين على
قانون يهدد عمل وسائل الاعلام والمنظمات
غير الحكوميه ويلزم مشروع القانون اي
منظمه تتلقى اكثر من 20% من تمويلها من
خارج البلاد بان تسجل نفسها على انها ضمن
الوكلاء الاجانب والا ستواجه غرامات باهضه
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الداخليه الجورجيه عن
احتجاج 77 شخصا في الاحتياجات ومحاوله
اقتحام البرلمان المعارض المعارضه في
جورجيا تتهموا حزب الحلم الحاكم بالقرب
الشديد من موسكو وانه ياخذ البلاد في
اتجاه اكثر قمعا بدليل مشروع القانون
الجديد القامعي كما تسميه المعارضه وتساند
رئيسه البلاد المعارضه في الموقف الذي
قالت انه يذكر بقانون روسي استخدمه على
نطاق واسع لقمع
في ردود الفعل الدولي اتهم رئيس لجنه
التشريع الدستوري بمجلس الاتحاد الروسي
اتهم الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
بمحاوله تنفيذ انقلاب غير دستوري في
جورجيا المسؤول الروسي اعتبر انقلاب
المدبر كما وصفه هوارد على محاوله جورجيا
فهم ما يحدث بشان التمويل الاجنبي للعديد
من المنظمات غير الحكوميه على اراضيها وفق
قوله
ومن واشنطن بل اقر مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي
اذا الذي يهيمن على اليمين ماده رئيسيه في
مشروع لتعديل النظام التقاعدي تنصه على
رفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما وذلك
على اثر معركه اجرائيه حاده مع اليسار
وصوت من الاعضاء لصالح رفع سن التقاعد
مقابل 115 عضوا صوت ضده وياتي الماده غدا
تتظاهرات حاشده جارت في فرنسا وشارك فيها
اكثر من مليون شخص وفقا لوزاره الداخليه
احتجاجا على نظام التقاعدي في فرنسا
اطلقت شرطه مكافحه الشغب التركيه مسحوق
الفلفل لتفريق مجموعه من المتظاهرين
تشاجروا مع قوات الشرطه في نهايه مسيره
للاحتفال بيوم المراه العالمي في وسط
اسطنبول
في يوم المراه العالمي مسحوق الفلفل
لتفريق المتظاهرات في تركيا
[موسيقى]
خطه مكافحه الشغب التركيه اطلقت مسحوق
الفلفل لتفريق نحو 2000 امراه في وسط
اسطنبول
السلطات المحليه كانت قد منع التنظيم اي
مسيره او احتجاجات او بيانات صحفيه في وسط
المدينه
التركيات اثناء محاولاتهن دفع دروع الشرطه
دعينا الى استقاله الحكومه
المتظاهرات هتفنا لن نسكت ولسنا خائفات
ولا ننحني
الاشتباكات مع الشرطه تاتي قبل اكثر من
شهرين من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه التركيه
افشل مجلس النواب الامريكيه تمرير مشروع
قرار قدمه النائب والجمهوري يدعو الرئيس
جو بايدن الى سحب القوات الامريكيه من
سوريا ودعما لهب القرار صوت 103 فقط
لصالحه فيما صوت 30021
قال مبعوث الامم المتحده الخاص لسوريا ان
المناخ الدولي اليوم قد يجعل الحل الشامل
في سوريا مستحيلا مشيرا الى ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا لها تاثير سلبي يعطل من مهمه
السلام
ان المناخ الدولي اليوم قد يجعل الحل
الشمل مستحيلا لا يزال يتعين علينا السعي
لتحقيق ذلك لنكون صريحين عندما ننظر الى
الحرب في اوكرانيا والتاثير الذي تحدثه
فانه لا يساعدنا في تسهيل ذلك لكن كما قلت
لا يمكن قبول الوضع الراهن نحن بحاجه الى
المضي قدما وفي نهايه هذه النشره نذكر
بعبرز العناوين
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين
في عمليه اقتحام لبلده جابع في محافظه
جنين
مغارات روسي عنيفه على كييفو اوديسيا
ومحطه زابوريا النوويه دون كهرباء ومقتل
اربعه
[تصفيق]
تحت ضغط الشارع واحتياجات العنيفه طالما
جورجيا يسحب قانون الوكلاء الاجانب
نهايه هذه النص المشاهدين شكرا لحسن
المتابعه وكونوا فيها
[موسيقى]